I'm mislead some new rules to protect
parliamentary staff from harassment to
be voted on this week you said there at
the cross party review I mean is this
the system that will finally put an end
to the poor behavior well and even worse
well I sincerely hope so when the Prime
Minister asked me to chair that group it
really was an enormous amount of work we
took huge amount of evidence from
different groups from staff from people
who work around an in Parliament and yes
I think what the ambition is is to be
amongst the best employer and place to
work and be treated with dignity and
respect and that is the plan well we
wish you well with that a simple
straightforward question will we be
coming out of the European Union on
March the 29th 2019 yes we absolutely
will that is as the Prime Minister made
clear right from her Lancaster House
speech we will believe in the European
Union the single market the customs
union will be taking back control of our
borders and our laws and that is
absolutely our plan I mean well you well
we though I mean this is a confusing
thing to me on on the 30th of March 2019
we'll still have ECG oversights or no
sovereignty we won't even have the 350
million pounds that was promised for the
NHS we we won't have complete control of
our borders and what way is that leaving
the European Union well what we are
seeking to do is to get the best freest
possible trade deal with our EU friends
and neighbors that's in all of our
interests that we do that we'll be
continuing to collaborate together on
issues around security and in terms of
how we approach the rest of the world on
foreign and defence and so on but at the
same time we want to make sure that for
businesses and for individuals living in
the UK and around the EU only have to
make one set of changes so we'll be
having an implementation period that
means that the changes that take us to
our new relationship with the EU have
time to bed in and to be properly up and
running before such time as we finally
move to those new arrangements so we are
leaving the EU in March 2019 as set out
under all of our plans but at the same
time that implementation period will
enable us
smooth transition for businesses and for
people so what was agreed at Chequers
this week I wasn't there I knew you
weren't there but you're probably more
likely to have David Davis his mobile
number than I am
well essentially it was a very positive
discussion and the Prime Minister will
be speaking about that on Friday
following a further discussion with
cabinet so I can't give you details
right now with what was discussed but
suffice to say it was a very positive
discussion all of those who were at that
particular
sub-cabinet committee meeting were in
agreement at the end of it and the
intention is that we will indeed be
leaving the European Union and that we
will have arrangements for free trade
with our EU friends and neighbors that
work for all of us it did seem in the
immediate aftermath of the checkers
meeting that the harder brexit ears had
won the day all the talk was lobbed to
virgins but no we hear talk of of
managed diversion divergence of putting
different economic activity into
different baskets with with different
levels of divergence in what world will
the European Union agree to that because
it's not this one well you know the
reality is when you look at the
practicalities of trade there are
certain areas like certain supply chains
where it is vital for all interests that
you have similar rules in other areas
where there aren't complex and time
limited supply chains is perfectly
possible to diverge and what the Prime
Minister's always been clear about is
that we will seek an arrangement that
works for all of us now our EU friends
export to us an enormous amount more
than we do to them it'll be in their
interest in the interests of French
farmers and the interests of German
manufacturers that they continue to have
free low or zero tariffs and zero or low
non-tariff barrier arrangements with the
United Kingdom but surely either the
European Union won't let us cherry-pick
which economic activity goes into which
basket you know you want to put the
automotive industry here you want to be
bits of agriculture here either that or
they themselves will cherry pick and
place economic activity into the baskets
that best suit them and we either
situation we come off for us well I
don't I don't agree with this actually I
think you know where we have close
collaborations with the EU as things
stand today we
have exactly the same rules you know
we've been exactly implementing the same
rules directives legislative
arrangements as the EU in terms of trade
for the last 43 years so when we start
in our new relationship outside of the
EU through our EU withdrawal bill we
will have brought into UK law all of
those rules and regulations so the day
after we leave things will look exactly
the same as the day before we leave so
it's at that point it's there where
you're looking at what areas will we
want to diverge away possibly in the
area for example animal welfare where
possibly we will want to have higher
standards or in the areas of financial
services where financial service is a
very big part of our economy much more
so in relative to the size of our
overall economy than is the same for the
European Union and we may want to have
slightly different rules and it should
be possible in agreement among sizeable
but it's difficult to see that the
European Union will agree to this I just
want to ask a quick question though do
you do you ever sit at night by the fire
with your head in your hands and think
do you know what I could do a better job
than Teresa I I think this is an
incredibly complex negotiation and I
think that the Prime Minister is doing
the most amazing job she is trying to
tread a fine line between negotiating
with the European Union and at the same
time accommodating the views right
across the house which are very varied
from those wanting to just reverse the
referendum to those genuinely wanting to
improve the legislation and what I'm
really pleased is to have the job of
trying to help her in listening to all
those different views across Parliament
to taking them into account to adopting
all those ideas that do improve the
legislation and to persuading people
where it's not going to help the United
Kingdom or the EU to back away from
their proposals so my role in helping to
facilitate our domestic readiness is one
that I am thoroughly enjoying doing so
no I I don't wish I was doing her job at
all